launches threads to rival Twitter says
10 million people signed up in the first
few hours
[Music]
[Applause]
and the money transfer group cab
payments debuts on the London Stock
Exchange in one of the biggest
flotations this year
[Music]
good afternoon this is Ian King live
business life with Ian King the chief
executive of HSBC UK has insisted Savers
can get good interest rates if they shop
around Ian Stewart was speaking as he
and other bank Executives met officials
from the financial conduct Authority
amid accusations that lenders are
profiteering from rising interest rates
they've been accused of being quick to
raise mortgage rates while failing to
pass on the benefits to Savers is what
Ian Stewart told Sky's Paul Kelso as he
arrived for the meeting
and what will you say in respect of the
Savers rights I don't know because I
don't know I'm going to be asked okay
come on some great savings rates out
there though just encourage people to
get online get some great savings rates
business correspondence at the fca's
headquarters in Stratford pool any
readout yet from the meeting
uh waiting for a formal statement in
from the meeting but I've just spoken to
Sheldon Mills of the financial conduct
Authority he was pleased that when the
invitation was it an invitation or was
it really an order given that the
chancellor had expressed a concern about
the level of savings rates whatever it
was it drew bosses senior figures Chief
Executives uh almost all the chief
Executives from nine of the biggest
banks in Britain uh arrived here at the
office to talk about whether Savers are
getting a fair deal we've seen uh
mortgage rates two-year fixes Rising
above six and a half percent because the
bank rate has gone up as we know but the
savings rate for instant access is
lagging nearly four percentage points
behind you can get just over two and a
half percent you tie your money up you
can get a better rate
um certainly for title for a year and
that is what Ian Stewart was talking
about uh when I spoke to him on the way
in but speaking of the Sheldon Mills
just now he shared the view that there
are good rates out there what he wants
the banks to do is ensure that as many
customers possible get access to those
rates and people are encouraged to save
this is what he told me
Savers are getting value and I think
when you think about value in retail
banking you've got to think about the
wide range of products that people have
current accounts lending products credit
cards savings and mortgages the banks
provide all of those Services as well as
lending to small businesses in that
context there is value being provided we
have though been working with banks for
a number of months to just ensure that
as base rates go up
um you know the right level of value is
going through to all of those customers
uh the question is what's the FDA going
to do next well there will be a report
at the end of this month in which
they'll set out a little more formally
uh the um actions that have Arisen out
of today's meeting bang boss is not
massively Keen to talk about it Charlie
I'm from Lloyds did stop and talk to me
on the way out he said it was positive
he also thinks there are good rates out
there but perhaps he would wouldn't he
but the banks clearly realize they are
under pressure here this has some
political weight at the moment given the
wider cost of living crisis that should
be said we're focusing on savings here
that's a nice problem to have in this
economic climate what most people many
more people are worried about how they
can get to the end of the month with
their bills rather than how much they
consult away and what deal they'll get
for it and the pressure I suspect in
this debate around where Bank rates are
and what rates are offered to borrowers
and lenders will soon switch as more and
more of fixed rate mortgages come up and
people find themselves facing much
increased monthly bills to meet their
mortgage the pressure here and on the
banks and from the financial conduct
authorities will be how people are
treated fairly by the Banks as they
begin to struggle rather than what they
can do with what money they're lucky
enough to be able to put away
thanks Paul
a Facebook's parent company meta today
unveiled its long-awaited competitor to
Twitter the app called threads allows
users to publish posts of up to 500
characters long and includes links
photos and videos
meta's chief executive Mark Zuckerberg
used his own threads account to announce
that the platform had signed 10 million
users during its first seven hours while
joining me now is the technology
journalist will guide who's also a
former meta employee will welcome to you
what's a motivated meta to do this
there's a few things I think uh Ian they
very clearly wanted to enter into this
space for a long time we've probably
nearly all forgotten that Mark
Zuckerberg tried to buy Twitter in 2013
for 500 million dollars didn't get
anywhere with that and then quickly
moved on to buy Instagram for two
billion dollars he's always fancied the
idea of a text-based service they've
been working on it for a while I kind of
truly believe that the little bit of
rivalry and needle between Mark
Zuckerberg and Elon Musk has turned this
into reality I also do not think it is a
coincidence that has suddenly launched
this week after we had a weekend of
truly bizarre behavior from Elon Musk
over at Twitter
but Elon Musk is struggling to make
Twitter profitable why would Mark
Zuckerberg want to set up a copycat
which has no guarantee of being
profitable itself well it will become
profitable the moment he switches on
Advertising that's the thing it's been
built within matters advertising network
uh they're not running ads on the
platform right now but the idea is this
is another part of the meta ecosystem
where they can serve you heavily
targeted adverts it's very strange Ian
as to uh the fact that we've all or many
of us have seemingly jumped back into
the warm embrace of Mark Zuckerberg
after many people spending a great
period of time questioning just how much
uh Freedom meta had to use your data
selling it to others and also selling
advertising or targeting advertising at
you
that's very interesting because there
are rival platforms out there the likes
of Master Dawn and blue sky and not to
mentioned Donald Trump's truth social
history was like
that's the yeah
this might this from what you're saying
stands a chance of taking business away
from Twitter I think it will kill
Twitter I will go that far and I will
say uh there will be the people who want
to stay with Elon Musk and his Free
Speech platform but the place where the
audience already exists Ian is over on
meta's platforms the number you were
giving earlier of 10 million or whatever
it was with uh Mark Zuckerberg we're
talking nearly 20 million now just
several hours on when you consider that
Twitter has stayed around the 350
million active users for about five
years even when it had Donald Trump
tweeting from the White House toilet as
every opinion as the leader of the the
you know the leader of the Free World
that platform never grew within the
first 24 hours this platform from meta
could have 10 of that audience already
so uh if if uh Twitter was worth uh 40
odd billion dollars when he purchased it
Fidelity was saying it was worth 15
billion potentially last week it could
be worth half that by this time next
week if users go I've had enough of Elon
Musk in his Antics I'm going elsewhere
if it really starts to and the people
who've been using it for the first day
keep coming back and more and more
people keep signing up you don't need
Twitter anymore very interesting that
you make uh the point there about Elon
Musk I mean do you think one of the
strengths here is that meta's been
increasing its spending on platform
moderation at a time when twit has been
cutting back on its own well let me give
you an anecdote I spotted this weekend
on Twitter the whole film the most
recent Spider-Man film only recently a
year or so out of the cinemas and still
on Sky movies and in all those places
was posted in full to Twitter on
Saturday evening it stayed there on the
platform before it was removed Monday
morning if something like that had
happened on one of Zuckerberg's
platforms or YouTube it would have been
removed by an automated system within
minutes that's the Bonkers thing here I
don't know what Elon Musk has done in
terms of we know he's laid off an awful
lot of people and he's claiming he
didn't need all those engineers and
Specialists to keep this platform
running but anecdotally we've seen the
attitude towards copyright become very
relaxed but on the opposite side of that
independent experts not people like me
who don't like Elon Musk are claiming
that hate speech Etc have rocketed on on
that particular platform
um what what meta does incredibly well
it has scale Mastodon and blue sky and
all of those other places we've talked
about simply couldn't cope with the
number of users signing up at any one
point at the point where Mastodon has
had big sign ups uh splurges it's often
gone down or crashed or you've not been
able to sign up uh musk and um musk
would be won't simply won't be able to
compete with uh what the guys meta are
able to do here they've got the scale
and they've got the engineers
all right well we've got to leave you
there good to talk to you today thank
you
some other business news stories for you
now and shares of cab payments have
fallen by 10 this afternoon after the
company made its debut on the London
Stock Exchange this morning well the
company which specializes in
facilitating foreign exchange and
cross-border transactions in Emerging
Markets was valued at
854.851.4 million pounds of flotation
making it large enough to enter the ftse
250 index the flotation one of the
biggest so far this year is being seen
as a test of confidence in the UK stock
market which has seen a dearth of IPOs
this year I'm pleased to say the chief
executive of cab payments by travardi
will be appearing on business live
tomorrow morning
the tour operator jet2 predicted a
strong Summer today after reporting
results that topped its last year of
trading before the pandemic jet2 which
now claims to be the UK's largest
package holiday provider and third
largest airline by number of passengers
flown reported a pre-tax profit of 371
million pounds for the year to the end
of March that was up from a loss of 389
million pounds during the previous 12
months but it was also up 48 on the year
to March 2020. well the company which
recently announced plans to begin flying
from Liverpool John Lennon Airport from
next march said it would be offering
seven and a half percent more flights
this summer than last year
an activity in the UK house building
sector slumped to its lowest level for
more than 14 years outside the pandemic
it emerged today the purchasing managers
index survey for the construction sector
in which anything above 50 represents
growth and anything below that a
contraction came in at 48.9 in June that
was down from 51.6 in May it was the
first contraction for the sector in five
months but the reading for residential
house building came in at just 39.6
meaning that activity contracted at the
steepest Pace since May 2020 s p Global
which compiles the data said that aside
from the lockdown related fall in-house
building the rate of contraction was the
fastest since April 2009.
now there's a big shake-up of insurance
regulation coming with changes to the
solvency 2 rules that dictate how much
Capital insurers must hold and where it
can be invested the government and the
industry say the reforms will allow
significantly more to be invested in
productive Assets in future well to that
end the association of British insurers
has today launched a new investment
delivery Forum to help Drive investment
into UK infrastructure projects well
joining me now to talk about this is
Hannah gergy the director general of the
ABI Hana very good to see you today for
those who haven't been following the
stories how does solvency 2 inhibit
investment
well it's great to be here with you and
today as we launch our investment
delivery Forum the insurance and
long-term savings sector in the UK is a
powerful Institutional Investor and
firms are already investing across the
country in large-scale infrastructure
projects but the Prudential regulatory
framework which was called solvency 2
and in the future is going to be called
solvency UK is being reformed by the
government to enable investment in a
broader range of productive assets and
we're excited about that because it
means as an industry we can do more to
deliver better returns for Savers but
also to help power economic growth and
do more to help the environment so how
will this forum be driving that
investment well the Forum is going to be
chaired by baroness Nikki Morgan who is
the chair of the association of British
insurers and it brings together leaders
from Seven founding members there'll be
household names that are familiar to you
Aviva Phoenix and others and that Forum
will oversee Three Delivery groups that
are focused on energy networks energy
generation and housing those sectors
deprived of capital at the moment
because of solvency too though
so the areas that we as an industry
believe the UK will need increased
Investments if we are to meet the
objective of Net Zero in 2050 and there
are also areas where our industry has
expertise and where we feel lessons can
be learned to potentially apply to other
areas across the country that would also
benefit from investment and why those
areas in particular because those are
the areas that you feel are most in need
of capital
our industry has a strong social purpose
at its core and the ABI has a purpose of
investing in protecting people and
planets but as an industry we have to
have the interests of Savers at the
heart of everything we do and we feel
that investing in these types of areas
across the country in the regions and
the devolved administrations is really
going to deliver the benefits that
people want in their retirement but day
to day will have a great impact on their
everyday lives some of these long-term
infrastructure projects so for example
as risk-free as they may appear I'm in
you look at the situation with Thames
water right now I'm sure members of the
USS pension scheme are not delighted at
how that investment's going
all of our members and those that will
be involved in the Forum have to look at
the risk and the reward and make sure
there's a balanced approach that
delivers the best outcome for Savers so
we'll be working closely with other
partners central government local
government as well as other bodies such
as 3ci that have a strong focus on how
to help green the economy and support
neighborhoods as they're going through
the transition to Net Zero there's been
a bit of anxiety in some quarters not
least they're in the Bank of England
that doing away with solvencity or
watering it down increase the risks for
for policyholders what do you say to
those people the reforms that will be
introduced through solvency UK will mean
that the UK continues to have one of the
most robust Prudential regulatory
regimes for insurance in the world
policy holder protections remain in
place but what the reforms allow is
investment in a broader range of
productive assets and that's for the
good of the Savers but also for the good
of our country all right Hannah I've got
to leave it there good to see you today
thank you thank you
still to come here on business live
we'll be having a look at how the
markets have finished this Thursday
afternoon stay with us
[Music]
thank you
the band has rallied moderation interest
rates peaking up and up at six percent
the highest for 14 years will that be
the peak will it be a little bit lower
prices is closer to a potential crash so
many words so many meanings but what do
they mean for you and your finances stay
up to date on Sky News I'm Martha
Kellner and I'm Skye's U.S correspondent
based here in Los Angeles it's turning
everybody into a crazy violent drug
addict
how are you feeling
are you a hypocrite sir will your
candidates win I hope so I gotta be
realistic my sister's dead
more than four weeks on there's no
murder weapon and no suspect
Mom how are you feeling today Jeffrey
said you answered together you just
don't cross her I'm so excited severe
nightmares of these people coming in and
just taking me in the middle of the
night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster I'm alive and
I'm thankful for that we take you to the
heart of the stories which shape our
world a lot of cases that I know are
reported from Ukrainian missiles
themselves Ambassador with respect I
think that's preposterous
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
till I Emirates it's like better
[Music]
Fly Emirates fly better
foreign
stocks in Europe have sold off sharply
this afternoon it's an absolute sea of
red out there that's on news that last
month saw much stronger than expected
private sector job growth in the United
States making the prospect of more
interest rate Rises likely from the U.S
federal reserve look at that off nearly
three and a quarter points on the
session it's a similar picture here in
London the ftse 100 has finished down by
more than two percent in a broad-based
sell-off it's hit its lowest level this
afternoon since the 20th of March
leading Fuller and percentage terms is
the gaming group flutter entertainment
meanwhile next and JD Sports both off
there that looks quite a sharp full but
bear in mind those stocks have gone
ex-dividend today in other words they're
trading for the first time without the
rights to the latest payout so don't
panic too much if you own those
particular stocks all of the house
builders meanwhile have also Fallen
sharply on the PMI data there are not
too many blue chip gainers to mention
this afternoon but United utilities is
ahead by one and a half percent or so
and that is after it got a push from one
of the Brokers outside the foot c100
curries is the biggest Faller it's off
by more than 12 percent that's after it
reported a drop in profits and said it
wouldn't pay a final dividend you might
recall we have Alex Baldock the CEO on
our morning program the office space
provider workspace meanwhile is off by
nearly five percent on a trading update
while the recruitment firm Robert
Walters is off by one percent that's
after it reported an 11 drop in
quarterly fee income well it's a similar
story on Wall Street right now Wall
Street is selling off very very sharply
on that jobs data the S P 500 the NASDAQ
and the Dow Jones Industrial Average are
all off right now by nearly one and a
half percent a piece there's also been a
sell-off in the bond market today the
yield on two-year U.S treasury bonds has
hit its highest level for 16 years the
yield of course uh Rises as the price
Falls here in London 10-year UK guilt
well the yield there has hit 4.661 that
is higher than they were prior to the
orb immediately after the mini budget
last Autumn you remember of course what
happened then on the foreign exchange
markets well the dollar has strengthened
on the job stage you can see Sterling
more or less holding its own there
against the uh the dollar in fact
looking at that the Dollar's given some
of those gains back as he offerings worn
off because it's slightly behind against
the Euro right now as well has affected
the oil price so the oil price tends to
work in an inverse proportion to the uh
Stronger dollar uh Battle of Brent crude
as you can see there changing hands at
75.65 cents a barrel that's off a little
over one and a quarter percent so
joining me now is George lagaris he's
Chief Economist at mazar's George good
to see you this afternoon I mean these
this job number I mean it's obviously
fantastic news for the US economy in
terms of the strength and resilience
it's showing but it does rather point to
more interest rate Rises
well yes okay it's a strong labor number
but really the sell-off we're seeing is
just a buoyant Market that's really hard
for for three weeks taking profit as it
comes to to terms with Federate hikes
and you know to be sure I honestly don't
understand what the surprise is we knew
that the labor market is tight we knew
the FED would be uh hiking further they
told us many times investors seem to
consistently underestimate the
determination of central banks to to
focus on inflation
so really what you're seeing is taking
profit I think you would see more
worries ahead if markets ever come to
the conclusion that central banks will
end up over tightening George do you
think this makes it now inevitable that
the FED is going to have to tighten
policy so much that we do get a U.S
recession
I think in network inevitable is a very
strong word but I think that's
definitely the direction of travel
um we had a very long period of very low
interest rates and then we printed a lot
of money and by the way the last round
of QE ended up in the pockets of
consumers which means it became very
inflationary and now we need to push
hard towards the the other direction you
know by in the U.S I would not be
surprised if we see a recession uh near
the end of the year or earlier next year
and in terms of when we start to get
interest rate uh Cuts I mean that looks
like it's heading further out into the
distance
ah I think those who are expecting rate
Cuts in 2024 might be negatively
surprised
um unless we see a sharper recession
than what we originally anticipated I
would put rate Cuts uh maybe in 2025
now George I mentioned in the market
report there Robert Walters pretty
disappointing trading update for them I
mean that is a pretty good barometer of
the labor market more broadly isn't it
well yes but look what they said there's
reduced levels of candidate confidence
and lengthening time to hire or signaled
in the second half of 2022 and I hear
that but Robert Walters is not really an
independent Prevail of Micro Data I
would read it more as anecdotal data the
labor market in the U.S the in the UK is
very tight unemployment actually fell in
April to 3.8 from 3.9 job vacancies are
roughly a little bit over a million
which is 63 percent higher than average
so I'd say that the labor market is
still very tight
and does and obviously that has a knock
on for a wage inflation which is
obviously the something the bank of
England is very worried about
yes so the UK more than other countries
in Europe has entered this wage price uh
spiral which is why UK interest rates
now need to rise more than than its
developed Market peers
okay George got to leave it there good
to talk to you this afternoon thanks
very much indeed for joining me
thank you
that's it from me for this afternoon I'm
back with another edition of business
live tomorrow morning at half past 11.
hope very much uh to see you then don't
forget we'll be joined by the chief
executive of Camp payments which made
its debut on the London Stock Exchange
today one of the biggest IPOs so far
this year and I can also give you a
little bit of breaking news from
headingley the Australians have just
been bowled out for 263 and Mark Wood
got a FIFA well done for him thanks for
joining me today hope to see you again
tomorrow cheerio
foreign